can you see why maybe now they gave him
money like i knew you said hard no no
way but if a guy's like let's we're day
together we're gonna
we're gonna look for apartments together
there's that emotional component right
there sure does that put yourself in
these women's shoes
i don't think i would put myself in that
situation like i'd be able to read
that you would call [ __ ] long before
amber any different perspective we're
just i guess in different periods in our
life than these women they were a
slightly older demographic they weren't
in their 20s right i mean there were
women who were a little bit more
established and had money or were
willing to put themselves in a financial
you're like listen i can't give you 10
grand if you wanted to go to chipotle i
got your baby
exactly and i think anything that i
think women were always kind of um a
little bit more protective of just
everything in general right i mean
physically that's why yesterday was i
was my alarm system went up um because
at the end of the day i need to i need
to provide for myself and i need to make
sure i'm okay and financially that is
those are my only assets right now so to
give that to somebody no matter how much
love they're like promising me unless
they had given me not just an experience
but actual money in the past if they had
given me 50 000 and i knew that like
that was something that an exchange was
happening that was possible sure maybe i
don't know but to give 30 000 or to take
out a loan that's a whole other story
take it alone you're ruining your credit
for somebody you don't know that well no
no [ __ ] way well not really that's
the thing they knew each other well i
mean yeah with all the i mean
okay i'll just say it but whatever uh
[ __ ] my feelings yeah yeah well here's
the thing women's feelings change a lot
when women are emotional creatures it's
easy for you guys here to say in 2020 i
would never do that but if a man showed
you a certain lifestyle he had a bunch
of social proof he's walking around with
security he's showing you his baby mom
you're riding in private jets you're
going all around the world he's uh
creating a certain lifestyle for you
right and you really feel like this is
going to be the guy and you've been
dating him for a year whatever
i beg to differ i think you guys would
send him that some of that money i don't
think you guys would be so well you know
what nah man i don't believe it
women are wrong
if he had money why is he asking me for
money well here's the thing he came up
with an elaborate story hey i was
assaulted my credit cards don't work
anywhere et cetera these
you know whole kevin hart thing my debit
card ain't attached to my credit card
checking account he i don't know the
story but he couldn't ask his family
members for the money
well the way he put it was his life is
in danger and he didn't want to be
traced so he had to use another name
right see i wouldn't be with somebody
whose life is in danger in this way like
some women are probably turned on
by
what i'm trying to say is that you you
would ask questions
to receive answers you get me like i'm
you're not just gonna send over thirty
thousand dollars without questions
the biggest part here is that like he's
someone you cared about was in trouble
and you kept on so much so you know what
damn
my soon-to-be husband or my my guy my
man is in trouble i need to help him
yeah that urgency there like you can't
you can't come up with that on the spot
it was built over time and if you care
about the person you know what damn it i
don't have the money right now but i'll
take a loan to help him because he's
going to pay me back maybe in the future
your rationale is going to go out the
window yeah and especially like i don't
want to sound like a jerk or a sexist or
whatever but women are emotional
creatures like women are ruled by their
emotions they like that is why this guy
was able to swindle he played the game
to his to women's weaknesses which is
their emotional you know instability a
lot of the times yeah and we are
emotional creatures i mean thank god we
we thank god we we create life inside of
us and we have to care for that life and
and i think it is you you did make a
valid point of saying that he he
appealed to those emotional lean needs
and was able to grab women i think um
a lot of men who are successful get a
lot of women because not only financial
needs but because they're able to use
that as an asset to get them in an
emotional state right so there's
definitely value and valid statement to
that i just think um
i do think that asking questions and
knowing more about your partner because
if he did he had multiple women i'm
assuming yeah but they didn't know that
right but i'm just saying like so time
right like if he had multiple women like
what was the time i'm sure he gave him
lies but as women deep down inside you
have an intuition and you're telling me
they were dating
for months or a year plus at a time so
again we don't know everything that
transpired because you're only going to
see the highlights from the show
but the fact that they sent the money
without necessarily asking too many
questions so easily and were willing to
take out loans and put their neck on the
line from a financial perspective to
help him tells me that he built an
enormous amount of rapport with these
women because he knew how to pick them
too yes
i don't think he would have targeted
somebody like jenny but here's the thing
i know for a fact the the fact that
these women gave him so much money
right when women are not built to be
providers for men tells me that he
played the game very well because he
took women out of their element right
use their emotions against them and turn
them into something they're not
typically used to being which is what a
provider for a man he was able to flip
the roles but you can only do that as a
man if you've built an enormous amount
of rapport right and attachment which is
what he did this guy's like the james
bond of ripping off women it's pretty
impressive what he's done and also just
yeah i pointed this as well
you don't know how a woman really cares
about you
it just spends her money on you because
real talk women and their money are kind
of inseparable they care about their
pets maybe themselves but really to
spend on their man it's not really uh
you don't say it out too often